if this is working properly
okay guys i think we are live uh i hope
you're live i hope you can hear me
and you can hear me fine so uh let's get
started i'm using
my canon so this is a little bit
different hopefully
the you know the audio quality the
overall video and audio quality is going
to be a little bit better
and i'm going to take a look at the some
of the questions that you've asked me
here and you've asked quite a few
and then we can get i think we can get
started
so um again thanks a bunch for uh
for showing up again um we
have been my team and i we've been
thinking about doing these uh q a
you know to keep them regular and uh
we hope we can keep going for a long
time
thanks so much for all the interesting
questions that you've been asking
so i think we're ready to go
uh dimitri nazarenko that's the first on
top um
hi luca do you have any tips for
learning portuguese what resources would
you recommend
to become fluent in the language and are
you planning to learn ukrainian greek
greetings from kiev ukraine thanks for
the question i've been to kiev
some four years ago was one wonderful
place i wish i could go back but now
it's a little bit complicated um
as far as portuguese is concerned the
first question you have to ask yourself
is do you want to learn portuguese from
portugal
or do you want to learn portuguese from
brazil
normally most people opt for
portuguese from brazil it's a little bit
more popular so
i think you should tell me which which
one you want to
you want you want to go for because it's
a there's a huge difference normally
i've been learning uh brazilian
portuguese from portugal
and i've been using asimil so um
portuguese asimo has actually two
versions
i think i have it here uh
i i think i can show it to you this is
the italian version
so this is in italian
it's a very very good book this is an
excellent book
i would start with that one and you can
have it for portuguese you know
portuguese brazilian as well you have
the the other version as well
so uh in order to learn so you ask a
bunch of questions in order to become
fluent in the language you have to use
some language learning material as a big
like for beginners
to get a solid grasp of the language and
then you have to possibly use other
authentic material like you can watch
youtube videos
or you can actually you should interact
with native speakers nowadays it's
really easy to find native speakers
you either hire a tutor to talk to or
you find a tandem to have conversations
because ultimately
if you want to learn a language you have
to talk to people
so um jose mozo
oh jose hi luca here from portugal
speaking of
about portuguese uh about how many
active words do you think
in the amount to speak a language of b2
level i guess that you want to say
uh you know trying to reformulate here
how many active words do you
do you need to know to speak a foreign
language i am not that big of numbers
when it when it comes to
um you know associating numbers with
fluency
truth be told it is important to know a
lot of words but i think that
the number of words that you can use is
just
a side of the picture you also have the
capacity of putting these words together
to form meaning in different
circumstances that's that's what i call
fluency so
i think that you have to know words a
lot of words but i wouldn't worry so
much about the number i would
worry more about um getting to know to
use the words that you
learned you're learning on the fly in
different situations
because ultimately i think that the
level of fluency
is a let's say that the sum of
experiences that you live
and i've really never counted the amount
of words
that i know i don't even think about it
i just like learn words
by exposing myself to interesting
content and then i use them in
uh interesting uh conversations in
different circumstances
to uh improve my level of
let's say confidence i believe that the
the level
of fluency is also a measure of the the
kind of confidence you have in the
language
so ciao luka ciao musti musti nasty i
don't know i don't wanna butcher names
guys
sorry i hope you're doing well i'm doing
i'm doing fine
uh here in brom with a pandemic but you
know
things are good i can't really complain
i hope you're doing well do you use your
language for work related purposes and
do you get a certification in this
languages you learned thanks for your
content thanks for the question
i use around six to eight languages
for a number of reasons in my you know
private life with friends etc
and i get to use them because i'm a
language coach so basically
i train a lot of students all around the
world and i train them in multiple
languages for example if a french guy
wants to learn russian
or a russian guy wants to learn french
or an american wanting to learn italian
or spanish or the other way around so i
get to speak these languages on a
on a weekly basis and on top of that i
use a number of languages
at home so as i always say if you want
to speak a bunch of languages
and by a bunch i mean at least four or
five six and you want to maintain a high
level
you might want to design a lifestyle
that entails the use of these languages
otherwise it's going to be quite
complicated to
maintain them so roy you're the best
look at greetings from peru thank you
thank you i don't know if i'm the best
but thanks for the compliment
jonathan hi luca do you recommend to
study two languages at the same time
since spanish is my mother tongue and
feeling too comfortable learning french
so i was thinking to start
uh retake german any tips i've been
talking a lot about learning two
languages at the same time
and there's a lot of things to say but i
first i would not
generally recommend to learn two
languages at the same time
from scratch and if they're similar
that's even worse
but if you wanna as you're saying here
that you've been learning french and if
you're comfortable with it
i i don't see any reason why you
shouldn't go for german
you can actually learn german and at the
same time
um have a schedule or design a time
schedule where
you're not going to forget french this
is my piece
of advice normally a common mistake is
when someone starts learning a new
language they forget about the other
languages and this is also
a problem for me every time that i learn
a new language i want to make sure
that i also take care attend to the
other languages like
you know when your family is growing you
have a new kid in the family you want to
take care of the other kids as well
the new kid um you know necessitates
needs your attention by the other kids
as well
otherwise they get jealous so even if
it's two languages
a new one from scratch and the other one
uh you have to design a schedule where
you're basically spending the bulk of
your time let's say of your attention to
the new language but then do not forget
um attending to the other language by
maybe listening to it
listening to in your case probably to
french for five minutes or ten minutes
so uh
do something with that language
otherwise you tend to forget it and
becomes rusty
so um brandi slive i think that's your
name ranislav
hi again lucas so this is my schedule
monday friday i study two hours
each italian and english in the morning
in chinese in the afternoon on saturday
sunday learn only latin for two hours is
this a good way
it depends that depends on on what you
want to achieve
my schedule normally when it when it
comes to learning multiple languages at
the same time
my recommendation but again it's up to
you is to
kind of try to learn a bit of every
language every day
because by looking at the message here
if you study only latin
on sat saturday and sunday for two hours
you're telling your brain
that latin is less important than the
other so maybe that's the case but
in my case for example now i'm learning
actively pursuing
um greek hungarian and danish what i do
is i try to learn
a little bit of each language every
single day maybe 20 minutes a day
for each language because this way my
brain knows that they're all
more or less equally important so i do
not rotate and i do not recommend
you uh i mean you you can do that if you
want to
um but i would recommend slightly
changing the schedule so that you're in
daily contact with the language
maybe for latin would i might you know
uh recommend is that you do some latin
during the the week maybe five minutes
five to ten minutes and then you do two
hours uh in the
uh in the weekend when you have time but
again if you do just two hours
on saturdays and sundays then you're
telling your brain that latin is less
important
your brain gets a little bit confused
frequency is
is a lot is very important it's not just
intensity but also frequency if you have
frequency and
intensity so much the better
so um all black in latin music
don't you feel frustrated about the fact
that inevitably the language is dead
um you speak less get rusty and you lose
a vocabulary what can you do
to avoid that from happening well it's
impossible
to avoid that from happening unless
unless
i try to tackle 14 languages every
single day so
if you do the math that's that's
impossible i i don't i don't even want
to do that i'm a language buff
as much as i love languages i don't want
to spend the whole day thinking
that oh today is what saturday i haven't
done
all the 14 languages and so i feel bad
about it
it's inevitable to first to get rusty
in some of the languages absolutely
inevitable and
the other important thing is that if you
do not use a language it gets rusty
but your listening comprehension does
not get rusty this is the interesting
part
so if you reach a level where you
understand the language really well
it doesn't degrade that much you might
not you know
hear that language for 10 years but then
you will still
understand it well speaking
unfortunately the grades
the grades fast so on the one hand you
can design a plan where you can
get to speak or use the language or your
languages but
there's a limit even as i said at the
beginning even if i have designed a life
where i use
get to use let's say eight languages on
a weekly basis unfortunately
there are still languages that suffer
like swedish
or chinese or japanese even portuguese i
don't use it that much but
thank god it's so similar to spanish
that speaking spanish helps me
retain portuguese in some sort of weird
way but that's what happens
but i don't think you should worry about
it it's just inevitable you know it's
like getting old
you can get frustrated about getting old
but that's
just happens so i wouldn't fret
that much about it i wouldn't worry too
much about it but i would try
to at least maybe design some time where
you even talk to yourself you know if
you don't have
anybody to talk to if it's one two three
languages i think it's feasible if it's
14 or
10 or 5 it gets a little bit more
complicated unless you work with
languages
um so uh
andy franco i feel that i can't speak
english sometimes i think in english but
when i try to speak i forget
uh all that i want to say any tip i
think i have to speak more
but that's it you have to practice as
much as as possible
if you do not practice sometimes you
tend to forget but you also have to
remember that
no no there's different situations in
life no two situations are the same
sometimes we tend to think that we are
i'm pretty sure this has happened to all
of you and
myself included so sometimes you feel
like hey i feel
uh you just had a great conversation on
skype with someone you felt comfortable
with
and then all of a sudden you felt you
you went somewhere maybe at a bar you
met some people
and you felt uncomfortable around one
person or
because of a specific situation and you
could not put
you know put sentences together that
happens our language competences skills
you know change with time it's not
always the same my simple advice would
be just
talk as much as you can get as many
experiences as you can
after the pandemic after this pandemic
is over they're going to be plenty of
possibilities and talk to yourself if
you can something i
do all the time is talk to myself in the
languages uh that i
am learning for example today i woke up
at 6 45 even it's a saturday
and i talk to myself in greek for 30
minutes i have a
a technique that i use you know it's not
that i just talk
in a vacuum i use some notes special
notes uh
but it still it makes me speak even if i
do not have
anybody to talk to on that precise
moment it helps me speak
so we get good at what
we do stuff and we do it regularly
so um gabriela maria bologne
gabriella i would like to ask you how to
improve english pronunciation and the
flow of our
speech this is a big one so for the sake
of brevity and simplicity i
can't really articulate a long answer
because it might take three hours but to
make a long story short i think you have
to
learn to listen attentively to the
sounds and possibly
read out loud and get corrections uh
so ask a native speaker first you can
for example start reading
things out loud you can listen to a
podcast that has a script
you can listen to it then you can read
it out loud yourself slowly
and then you can get feedback because
unfortunately
we are a part of our brain is blind we
know there are things that elude us
unfortunately some things we can figure
ourselves figure out ourselves some
others we can't
and having a native speaker pointing
mistakes or inaccuracies in your
pronunciation
um is is the way is the way uh to
to go but you should find someone who's
friendly and who's willing to help you
this was really in a nutshell because
the answer the the thorough answer will
be very long
anyway i've made uh maybe kevin kevin
and beth that they're
uh you know they're there in the chat
moderating the chat
uh kevin you can put some maybe um
a link i've i've made two or three
videos i think even five or more about
pronunciation how to improve your
pronunciation if you're right
how to improve your pronunciation tips
you can find both
uh not only videos but also articles so
kevin if you have if you have the
possibility just
you can put some links in there so hi
luka rudra hi rudra
so let me see hi luca i'm shy when it
comes to speaking with people in another
language what should i do to handle the
situation i speak four languages but
i haven't had a lot of chance to
practice
i'll i'll confess i'll confess something
i am also shy
it doesn't look like it because i have
built confidence through years but when
it comes to speaking a language
that i still do not speak let's say
fluently i'm still
shy there's still a part of me that is
screaming that little voice that is
screaming no no you're not ready yet
you're not ready yet
and i remember um it was until a few
months ago when i was learning i've been
learning greek for three and a half
years
i think i speak it decently now um
but i remember that when i ventured out
and i i first
started using what's up to send you know
real-life
messages that were outside of books or
outside of my
classes with my wonderful teacher dadia
i remember that i was
i felt uh like i i felt shy about it
it's like am i good enough and
maybe i'm not good enough and i was
thinking about it and i was jotting down
words to
to to think you know i i wanna i wanna
speak well but
at the end of the day i think that the
best way to go about it
is to just do it first it might sound
trivial if
in your case it feels very intimidating
uh to speak well maybe you can first
talk to yourself
start talking to yourself to get a
little bit more confident so that you
can
you know practice and the second uh
thing that i always always do is to find
a friendly person to talk to so you can
find a tandem or you can find
a tutor who can help you and then you
just hop on a call
and you get you establish a good
relationship with that person and once
you've done that
that's you know ninety percent of the
job i found for example daria
for greek that is as a tutor on ai tokai
and that is wonderful so we have we have
conversations every
single uh tuesday and then i built my
confidence through that
but even then i felt a little bit
uncomfortable when
the moment came to using the language in
real life situation so being shy being
uncomfortable
happens to everyone every time you learn
a new language you have the same feeling
at least that's what
that's i don't know about you guys but
that's that's what happens to me i feel
a little bit intimidated
uh about using the language that's a
human feel that's a that's human it's
only human because you're venturing into
unknown ground so to speak
so um gabriella maria you asked me
another question how can you reach c1
level in english
well you ask interesting questions
gabriella
open questions big questions um i would
say
also on my blog if you look for
deliberate practice and how to move from
b2 to c1
and if you write how to move to from b2
to c1
on youtube you will find two or three
videos even one i made in thessaloniki
which is in greece
um i was interviewed by jan van der aah
he's a he's a dutch guy and we i
basically talked for
i don't know 10 minutes about what you
could do to
move from b2 to c1 but to make a long
story short
you should always make sure that
whatever you're doing now you have to
tweak things so that
you are challenging yourself in all four
areas of language learning so if you're
reading
something you should maybe tweak it a
little bit so you're reading something a
little bit more difficult or if you're
reading in a slightly different way
and this goes for across all area you
know you have to do this with all areas
if you're speaking and having just a
single conversation on skype
maybe you should tweak things maybe
having preparing mini speeches
or describing images getting out of your
comfort zone so
that's how you move to the you know to
the to the upper level
and most people get stuck at b2 because
b2 means speaking a language rather
fluently
and then your brain is telling you you
don't want to you don't want to make the
effort
of make the extra effort now your brain
is sitting there
in your skull comfortable with the
language when you reach a b2 and they
you know you've noticed that we reach a
high level in a language when we go to
school basically in our native language
because they force us to do stuff
that we would not do ourselves like
writing dissertations or giving speeches
etc so
um moving to
the c1 c2 realm implies
a little bit of work that your brain
might not do maybe you you
want to do that but your brain resists
and for biological reasons
so um what do you do to learn languages
that are very close to your first
language
uh i lost you there because now we have
i'm sorry guys i'm going up again you
are asking
a lot of questions uh
let me check what do you think of cia
manic and the way he learns
languages see amenities another polyglot
i've
uh i i know of him in in the sense that
i've seen him
um on youtube but i confess that i do
not know him that
well and i don't know exactly what he
does um recently i i think i watched a
video where he was sitting in a
restaurant next to a chinese couple
and they were eyeing him like this and
he was just started speaking fluent
chinese and the girl was very surprised
i i don't know i don't know him so i
don't i don't know i don't know what to
say
i don't know how he learns languages so
um
then uh
my native language is polish i speak
french and taught myself spanish
the french version of assimil now that
my
espanol is okay i plan to learn in time
using asimo in spanish what do you think
i think uh
camille that if you feel comfortable
enough using
uh spanish that's fine we're learning
italian so
learning an l3 to learn l2 or the other
way around
that's perfectly fine if i normally use
my native language
you know and if i use another language
it's because i have no other choice
so for example i think if i have
say let me see here
this you should be able to see it it's
swedish and
it's uh i don't know if you can see here
maybe
here it's out of because of the canon
maybe you should
this is should be visible enough uh i
had no other choice but learned through
french
because there are no there is no swedish
uh learned swedish in
in italian for assuming so that's what
happened
uh but again you can do whatever you
want
if you uh if you
if you want to go for spanish you can if
you want to go for another language
for your name for your native language
it's also okay
bravo luca says your greek is very good
thank you uh
i i'm trying to do my best with but i
really
really uh i really like uh greek i just
fell in love with week and
hopefully i'm going to this greek school
in the summer in september if
uh mr corona allows me to travel before
i go to munich
i'm planning on going to munich in in
june and then to
poland to krakow in uh krakow
in english in july if things go well
yes sir luca have you ever thought to
learn have you ever thought about
learning turkish i said it because
hungarian is so similar to turkish
i'm not sure that hungarian is similar
to turkish i know that hungarian has a
lot of turkish words because
you know because of history but i have
turkish here i
always i have it here
i have arabic oops you can see here
turkish
and i have hebrew as well so i bought
while i bought turkish
i'm thinking whether the next language
apart from serbian which is going to
start in september is going to be
turkish
or arabic or hebrew it's between these
three and i really don't know which one
but let's let's see what happens uh
do you speak russian yes i speak russian
um
i i've been speaking russian for about
six fif 15 years well actually
i started learning russian in 2004 so
it's been almost 4
15 years a little bit more
but i have really started learning
russian for real
i would say in 2013 when i met my
ex-girlfriend
then when i went to moscow and then
things you know got to a different level
because
when you get a partner in the language
and it's easier to practice the language
and also the extra motivation came from
the fact that i went to russia
and russia is a really cool country so
when i went there i wanted to go there
again and started
you know learning russian at another
level uh although truth be told i speak
a little bit less now
but it's still one of the languages that
i like the most and i really like using
it and also
training people in it so
um let me see here
let me go down there's a lot of
questions
glad to be tuning in luca dr dor zetter
hoy the dollar sector is um he's a
student of mine
edward he's a fantastic guy he's got a
youtube channel too he speaks a bunch of
languages and we always have a lot of
time
a lot of good good uh conversations uh
so
nice to see you here edward so um let me
see
what's the best way to learn fluent
german from b1 to c1
i think i have already answered this
question um
so if you wanna uh there's a couple of
videos on youtube that where i talk
about
moving from b1 to b2 and from b2 to c1
but fundamentally traditional courses i
would avoid them i would find myself a
tutor to talk to
and i would consume as much interesting
and comprehensible material that you can
and now nowadays
on youtube and with podcasts and and
podcasts with transcripts you especially
with german you can do
you can do a lot of stuff um kevin maybe
you you can put the
the link we have resources on my on my
website and
you guys can take a look we have i think
12 or 13 languages and we have
jot it down you know we've put there a
lot of resources
and german has a lot of amazing
resources you know from b1 onward
so um saint perth
north cloud i'm currently learning
german language but i really find it
hard to speak in deutsch directly i
often tend to think in english first and
translating it in german in my head am i
doing it wrong
no you're not doing it wrong it's only
natural that your brain resorts to this
defense mechanism of using your either
your native language or a language you
know
well in this case i guess that english
is your second language um
i would say that one way of
minimizing this switch is to form
simple sentences normally what happens
and it happened to me tragically
the the case was tragic in japanese the
longer your sentence is the worse this
this gets so we are adults and we want
to
to speak in a very refined way
articulate we want to be articulate
and elegant and eloquent at the same
time but
if you still do not master either the
vocabulary
of a language or it's syntax so you're
not let's say
you you are not able to pull sentences
to to string sentences together in an
elegant way then
my simple suggestion is to say simple
sentences
and if you say simple sentences you're
not burdening your mind
and your mind will thank you for it and
then later you can always refine
embellish your sentences and make them
longer and more elegant so my piece of
advice is
speak in a simple way and that in turn
will cause your brain to think directly
in the language
you have to train your brain to you know
speak in a simple ways that's not
simple does not mean simplistic you have
to think in terms of communication
how can i get my message across in a
simple way this is what you have to
think about you always have time
to improve if you start with very
complicated sentences your brain
will go crazy and uh you will constantly
think through
either your native language or another
language and you will make double the
effort
your effort will be literally double
because you're thinking in english and
then you're translating everything
into the next language into your you
know a foreign language or target
language which is actually exhausting
uh kevin replied for me yes luca speaks
russian
suggest me some books to learn arabic
grammar i have just
asimil so i haven't
i haven't learned arabic yet so i'm not
sure how i can help you in this case um
so um
[Music]
pana yuan or something like that panna
yoannam
i must know luca when was the last time
you had a day off
like without any deep work not counting
watching tv series or reading books just
for pleasure
do you ever take days off panna uh
it's a very i don't know if your name is
panna or you wanna i don't know
but it's a very interesting question
and the answer is it's rare
that a day goes by without me learning
stuff
and but i don't you know it it happens
that i i take
days off in the sense that i do not work
but when it comes to learning i don't i
don't think that learning
uh necessarily is a bad thing for my
brain that for example
this morning i didn't have to work in
the morning but i wake up at 6 4
30 just first because i got used to
waking up early and then because
i have this burning desire to learn you
know my friends i
i i told recently a couple of friends to
wake up like a 10 especially
in the weekend they go like why would
you wake up at 5 or
5 30 or 6 30 if you can sleep until 8.
well first time
i found out that i'm a lion like
according to
you know there's a book that talks about
chronotypes
and i'm supposed to be a lion so i'm
very active in the morning but
uh i when it comes to learning i take
just a few days off
when it comes to taking days off in the
sense that i relax and
it happens you know on saturday i try i
try at least to have one day
off during the week but you you've asked
a very relevant question i've been
even thinking of taking um a day off
when it comes to technology so i think
that
sometimes i'm tired more not because of
work
not because of the way i organize work
or because i learned too many languages
i'm exhausted because of the internet
because i tend to spend too much time
you know sometimes getting distracted
and
getting too many messages and looking at
youtube and then instagram that is what
it exhausts me
if i can take a day off which i'm
planning on doing
like from technology and having a
complete like
just just books or maybe just taking a
walk and no technology whatsoever no
phone etc i think that that is going to
be very
you know going to regenerate my mind
because we're constantly
bombarded by information and i think it
happened to you guys as well that when
we have a moment
ourselves we have time to to you know to
enjoy
uh the dawn uh to enjoy a dusk in the
park without any technology we have more
thought even in the shower we have
thoughts
like suddenly we have some mental space
to think about stuff and that doesn't
happen
uh most of the time when we're just you
know constantly bombarded by
stimuli and we're looking for the
stimuli this is the way
fundamentally the the internet is is
built to
make us uh addicted to it and we are
here on the internet
so um joe what other languages would you
like to learn let's see
a serbian in in september and then i
like to learn turkish
arabic and hebrew and then uh
you know when the moment comes i will
know i am not planning
specifically apart from these languages
on anything specific i will see
you know i'll see what happens in the
future i always say that languages
choose me
i do not choose languages so um
let me see here could you recommend some
really good books to learn japanese
i have one here i don't know though if i
can
get it let me see
there's one which is a really good book
but as of now here are
all my japanese books maybe you can see
a part of it i have
plenty of them but the one i'm looking
for
for some reason is not here i think it's
called
sentence patterns for effective
communication
in japanese i would highly highly
recommend that one i'm sorry i can't
find it for whatever reason
uh if i if i can find it later
uh i think that kevin can can find it i
think it's like sentence
efficient or sent something like that
sentence patterns for
uh efficient communication in japanese i
think that book is just great
um so
let's go down here where should you
notice
where should novice language learners go
for learning resources
well on the internet so i know it's a
little bit vague but you should write
like how to find good resources and
invest
30 1 30 minutes one hour two hours
looking for
good forms there are good forms that
talk about language learning you can
find them if you if you if you search
they're not difficult to find and then
my my suggestion
is to um to fundamentally spend time
invest time in finding resources and
then try a resource and if that resource
is not good for you move to another
resource
resources are really important if you
want to learn a language especially if
you want to learn a language
from scratch
daniele hi luca my daughter goes to
attends an international school
i talk to her in english oops something
happens here
so i lost you let me see here let me go
let me go up because again there was a
problem with the
uh you know with the chat so
you have a huge bookcase mohamed yes i
do this is this is just one i have other
books in in my other
in my other room daniela sorry i lost
your i lost your question
it got literally like buried here
so um he called simple doesn't mean
simplistic love that wonderful
explanation thank you thanks nicole
uh again yes we tend to think as adults
we want to
speak going back to what i was saying
before we want to sound refined
i think that simple is key einstein used
to say that you know
simple but not simpler it has to be
simple enough the most beautiful
theories are in in a way the simplest
ones and i think that
communication is about simplicity it's
not about complexity
of course you can you know you can
speak or you can express yourself like
poets or you can express yourself like
joyce or dante but dostoyevsky
but i think that nowadays especially
nowadays but in general
you have to aim at communicating we lost
as
as adults learning a foreign language we
have lost
the the the beauty of of communicating
with other people we tend to think
about language running as a performance
that's also the reason why
we all in a way to a certain degree were
kind of judgmental towards others oh you
you made this mistake you made that
mistake
we're not focusing on the message most
of the time we focus on the
on the performance and this is not only
how you know the comments that we
leave on youtube are a direct reflection
of how we
tend to look at ourselves so we we tend
to judge others but then we tend to also
judge
ourselves and fear the judgment of
others when it comes to speaking a
foreign language kids do not have that
so we tend to think oh if i speak in a
simple way then people are going to
judge me and i'm going to think that i'm
i sound stupid or i do not sound
sound like articulate that's not true
you have to think how can i communicate
effectively
first and then how can i refine my
patterns
later that's how it should happen
instead we have it the other way around
and that does
get in the way so uh
kulik three how to stop making the same
mistakes in the language
well i got a theory if you want to avoid
making mistakes the always the same
mistakes you have to be aware that you
make mistakes you have to have someone
point them to you and you have to have a
catch-to-fish system so you can jot them
down and work on them in
a with intention and attention that's
how i refine my mistakes
i pay attention to when people correct
me i do not i take it in stride so if
someone corrects me sometimes it stings
rarely it has happened especially when
you're not
asking for someone to correct you but
most of the time it's very useful
especially on youtube when i make a
video and i get corrections in english
or
even in italian sometimes and in other
languages first
the attitude counts like oh this guy
like this this
i made a mistake so that's great i've
learned something new instead of saying
oh i made a mistake bummer
that's the first thing and then again i
i've designed a system to jot down
mistakes so maybe you can create a
notebook of mistakes
and on the one side you can you can
write your mistakes in red on the other
side you can
maybe using color coding you can write
the correct version
in in green and then you can review it
on and off and try to apply
use these structures where you made
mistakes in conversation
otherwise you will you know make
mistakes over and over it depends on a
number of things on your attitude and
also on what you do with these mistakes
if you just want to communicate and you
don't really care about making mistakes
or you don't mind
people you know correcting your mistakes
and you don't pay attention you're gonna
you're bound to make mistakes over and
over
so uh live read
learn i love no live read learn actually
so i i like very much like your your
name
uh live read and learn hi luca thanks
for hosting this q a and for motivation
as much as your tips thanks thank you i
want to ask what can i do to advance
past an intermediate level of language
ability i hit a plateau for years
i've addressed this question before in
this
very same q a and and also in the other
q a's and i have some articles to talk
about that
and i have some videos so if you want to
look for more information
you should check like for example moving
from b2 to c1
um and if you write luca lampardelle on
google
you you should find both my youtube
videos and the articles
but to make a long story short and to
kind of rephrase what i said before what
you need to do
is you have to find yourself in a zone
of
uh slight discomfort so in other way
in other words you have to challenge
yourself if you get stuck if you got
stuck it means that
your uh your mind got got used to
certain
patterns and in order to move forward
you have to change those patterns so i
do not know you and i don't know
what you're doing uh now what activities
you're engaging in and what your level
is but
i suspect that what you're doing like
your brain got used to it
so you might enjoy those activities but
you have to
to you you have to venture out into um
your comfort zone and this means that
you have to venture into a zone
that is relatively safe it's called
i don't know if you've ever guys heard
about the zone of approximate
development maybe kevin can write it
here it's called what is a zone of
approximate development let me maybe
if i'm able to do that i'll i'll write
it in the chat
so this is a very interesting theory
let me see here i just put it myself
oops
well it for whatever reason i'm i'm
i'm trying to put it in the chat but
it's not working but if you write zone
of a proc so if you write on wikipedia
uh zone you can write it here
zone what is the zone of a prox proximal
development
proximal development you will find it
and basically
it's a theory in some you have to get
out of your comfort zone but stay within
a zone in which you
feel challenged but not too challenged
otherwise otherwise it gets
a little bit discouraging there's also a
book that talks about that
which is called peak which is one of my
favorite books i don't know where it is
now i can't find stuff today
but uh you should kevin can write it
it's
peak the science of expertise and it
talks about the theory of
moving forward of of you know getting
out of the rut of moving from
it let's say that it talks
about it touches upon the um
it talks about how people get the best
of the best become the best of
the best in their field so it approaches
this in a general way but it
applies to language learning as well
it's a wonderful book you should read it
and by reading it you will figure out
okay if you have a little bit of
imagination you can say okay i can apply
this to language learning how can i
apply it
it actually it's easier than you think
you
if you think about it read the book and
and and jot down a few notes because
it can really radically change the way
you learn
not just language writing so
um so how to master grammar of the
english language this is another big one
again i've made a lot of videos about
grammar how to learn grammar
if you write how to learn grammar luca
lamparello on google you will find
quite a few articles read by me so you
can read the article
the article or the articles you can
listen to it you can even watch the
video i think i have three videos on
grammar
but fundamentally to learn grammar you
have to learn it from language expose
yourself to comprehensible
and enjoyable content and you will start
your brain will start figuring out
grammar patterns uh by you know by
exposure but then you have to integrate
it with some
grammar rules with some grammar
explanations because
especially if the language is distant
from yours if the language is very
similar you might not even need to
like italian spanish but if a language
is quite different
or distant then you might need to have
grammar notes i always
like you know this book because this
book
asimil in general um provides
not only a i hope you can see it
you know not only provides a double
translation so you have the text in your
native language
this is in swedish and this is in french
in this case
and but then it also offers very
interesting explanation explanations let
me see if i
the thing is that if i i don't know if
you can see it here
but uh here you have some notes at the
bottom
and the book is great because um
the the whole philosophy is assimilate a
language
so they don't they don't bombard you
with grammar
but they rather show you how the
language works and then they
leave notes so that you can figure
things out yourself
and i think that's the way to go when it
comes to grammar
um so
let me see here panna i think panna you
have another question no that was the
same question as before sorry i'm going
back and forth
tom asks a question in german hello
um so i want to i want to learn swedish
as much as danish
which one should i should i learn first
and uh
which one is easier and how can i avoid
mixing them together it depends if
you're
a native german speaker um i think uh
they're equally difficult meaning
they're equally
i think i think they're very very
similar so
when i uh learned swedish i could
already
read danish without a problem um i think
they
have slightly they have different
features or quirks or whatever you want
to call it idiosyncrasies
swedish has is a semi or semi see me see
my
tonal language so for example you have
on then on then it's written the same
but it has a different
kind of tones even if you know it's
it's a little bit complicated to explain
this now in in two minutes but there's
a couple of wonderful videos on youtube
explain this in detail
so that's the difficulty when it comes
to uh
pronunciation danish is difficult to
pronounce
the danish you don't read it as you as
you
as you speak it so it's quite difficult
i would go
i'll go so far as to say that danish is
as difficult as english when it comes to
pronunciation and english is notoriously
difficult
even if it seems like oh everybody
speaks english but speaking english well
with accurate pronunciation that's a
different ballgame
so um but again i i think you should go
for the language that you want to learn
the most
i i don't know i'm not in your head so
if i think you should
delve a little bit more into i don't
know swedish culture and danish culture
and then you decide
the only piece of advice i would give
you is to learn a language well before
you move on to the other do not learn
both at the same time you're going to
get confused
so if you learn if you decide to learn
danish learn danish learn it well
then learn swedish or the other way
around
otherwise you risk you know confusing
them
so you have a huge bookcase i've seen
this before
so let me go down to the end of the chat
so could you please tell me about a
normal day what you usually do
um you guys have asked me this question
before and if you're interested i can
tell you very briefly well i
kind of tend to wake up at 5 45 and then
i make the bed
which is i think i said this in the
other q a the last q a i make
i make my beds which gives me a little
bit of
um you know discipline there's even a
book that talks about that then i i
i prepare breakfast i have breakfast
then i have a journal of
i write for 10 15 minutes about my life
what happened in the previous day
so that i can have some sort of brain
dump i can dump my ideas
into the google docs i have i free my
mind so to speak
and then i do meditation that i do uh i
started
doing workouts in the morning for 30
minutes then i take a shower while i
take a shower
i always listen to polish for 20 minutes
15 20 minutes i don't know if you ever
heard of spreaker
so not speaker but spreaker i've been
using spreaker
spreaker.com unfortunately i don't think
i can write it here
so it's just speaker with an r
spreaker.com and
i always always i don't i don't use
spotify
uh to listen to podcasts or any or
itunes i just use spreaker
especially for polish i always write now
i like it because the system is based on
tags so i just write now
learning and i find all all the
resources and all the podcasts
that you can you can think of then after
taking a shower i have a 30 minute
session of greek and then around 8 39
i start working and i call it deep work
deep work means to create scripts for
videos
or to write articles and now i'm
working on a big project so this is
taking most of my
mornings you will see this it will you
will see the light sooner or later
sooner than later actually i'm working
on it with my team and then i
have lunch and while i have lunch i
watch for example
i i listen to oh i forgot to say that i
have a reading session in the morning
always
before before or after greek so for 30
minutes
i read something that is useful for my
business or for my personal growth
then i you know going going back to
what i was saying i have lunch while i
have lunch i either
watch some comedy shows like stephen
colbert you know
and various american shows or i watch
news in russian or french
so france24 is my favorite news channel
and i i watch 10 minutes of it or 20
minutes depending
then i have um then basically
i read after lunch for 30 minutes
another book so i have three different
books that i read every day three
different sessions
then i have siesta for one hour without
that i will not be able to wake up this
early
and then i keep oh i work but i do some
kind of
uh you know it's not creative work it's
more like answering emails
uh you know stuff that requires less
mental power or energy
and then now that the second trip
you know the the april has started the
summer in a way has started
i go running between six and eight try
to run um
in in this beautiful park next next to
my place for
a couple of hours so i run for an hour
and then i walk for an hour
then i come back then i eat i watch some
other news especially in polish and
tifo and 24 and then i
normally after 8 30 i turn off all
screens and i start reading for one hour
and
one hour and a half and around 10 i go
to sleep
there's many other things happening
depending on the day but this is like
normally from monday till
thursday you know then friday is my uh
students day when i teach
and then i have saturdays and and and
sundays are a little bit different
uh you know there's um
uh there's a lot of uh other details
in general but uh this is more or less
that
you know how i organize my day
he's asking if i'm you know got a cold a
little bit but i'm fine
uh when are you making a video of your
bookshelf soon i'm reorganizing my
youtube channel so you guys are seeing
that i'm
i'm posting um you know shorts on
mondays
and i am or you know reorganizing the
way i make videos so it's taken some
time unfortunately but i'm gonna go back
to
producing videos every thursday very
soon and one of the videos is definitely
about books and about my bookshelf
uh how to learn to write in a foreign
language that's a big one
so it's i would i would say it
it takes time takes practice you have to
you know you have to
i haven't i've never written an article
i was about to say you can go to my blog
and check it out
check out an article i've written but i
haven't so it's about time that i write
about that
um why do you say that language
shows you are not vice versa well
because um as i said
looking back i think that i choose
languages but in reality there are
things happening
in my life sometimes it's because i met
a person
sometimes it's because i watched a movie
i went to a country that it like
sparked the interest for example i can
give you a very specific example the
reason why i've learned dutch is because
i met a girl i met a girl in sardinia
some i don't know 25 years ago and then
i
i started learning dutch because of
because of her and i remember that
i learned dutch and in two months i
started learning like crazy and then i
popped up in front of her apartment
uh it was next to in dinha
i was there you know it's a crazy story
but uh
i dutch chose me not i didn't i didn't
choose dutch
so um
so let me see here let me go down a
little bit more so i can see the
uh what was the hardest language okay
now i'm i'm at the bottom here to have
so many questions guys
como mantienes los idiomas how do you
maintain languages i basically
designed a life where i use eight
languages every day for work as i said
at the beginning of the q
a so i can maintain maybe eight of them
on a good day
it ranges a minimum let's say that i
speak a minimum of four languages every
day to a maximum of ten
so let's say between four and and ten i
can maintain on a weekly or
monthly basis but some other languages
suffer
but fundamentally i work with languages
i work with a multilingual team
i have a multilingual environment i live
in a multilingual environment i have
friends for all over the world
either online and offline and i tend to
you know use
at least four to ten languages a day and
not only and i do not only talk i don't
only speak these languages but also
uh among the the many things i do i read
a lot of magazines
i read a lot of books i have a lot of
language habits where each room each
space of my
apartment is an activity that i do
linked to another activity like when i
cook
i i listen to stuff in french or in
russian right so
the 1 pm is kitchen
cooking eating russian and or french
so it's automatic for me it's become
automatic
otherwise maintaining languages is
extremely taxing is this really
difficult
uh because it requires so much energy
especially if you want to
maintain these languages at the very
high level that was in a nutshell
hi from lima peru south america relatos
de la vida real
hi hi from rome so
let me see here cuantos cuantos anos
creste wait wait wait
how many how many years do you think
it's going to take you
to speak uh to speak english fluently it
depends on how much time you put in
if you put in everything and how you do
things so
if you started right now from scratch
learning english if you do it the right
way you put a couple of hours a day or
three hours a day
i think six months is enough to start
having decent conversations and in one
year
you can achieve amazing goals amazing
stuff
the problem is that if you learn at
school then school normally slows you
down it's supposed to help you learn and
it's supposed to be the place where you
learn but you actually
it actually most schools are not saying
that all schools are like that
but in you know the school system
normally the education system tends to
slow you down but if you
learn how to do things and you put in
daily um
daily work and energy if you do it the
right way you might be surprised to
learn
that actually you're able to learn and
communicate in a foreign language in a
matter of months
not years so it really depends on a
number of factors though so i would say
ranges from say
six months to two years depending on
what you mean by fluency so there's so
many factors involved
that it's difficult to give a
one-size-fits-all
answer but you can learn faster than you
think that's the bottom line if you
learn how to do it
if you do it every day if you do it for
a long period of time
so um diana salinas duarte any advice to
lose fear of speaking i can't help feel
embarrassed sometimes
and as i said at the beginning diana i
can't help feel feeling embarrassed
sometimes myself
when it comes to speaking certain
languages in certain circumstances
i think that again the amount of
experiences that you live
so the amount of people you talk to the
amount of situations you expose yourself
to
will help you grow your confidence we
always feel
everyone even the people who seem very
confident they always fear a pang of
fear
they're always scared of something they
do not know or new situations
so you have to understand that this is
completely
normal but the way to fight it as
trivial as it may
sound is to have diff live certain
different situations um the more you
talk to people the more you'll realize
that it's no big deal you know and even
if you get
sometimes uh you know the rough patch
even if sometimes you stumble upon come
across people who are not
very likable so to speak that also is
part of life
and what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger they say
so let me see here
samus says ask something in french do
you prefer language courses
hussien polyglot i hope you pronounce as
well
uh do you prefer to hire a tutor to
correct your mistakes and you make your
own course if you do prefer the second
option what do you do after assuming
i like hiring tutors to help me
because you know language tandem is fine
but
they tend to be unreliable at least in
my case it's more difficult
to establish a long term relationship
with a tandem so i tend to hire tutors
but i tend to take initiative so for
example with
my tutor greek tutor dadia and with my
hungarian tutors i always take the
initiative of choosing
topics beforehand that really make me
tick and i speak a lot
and i get a lot of corrections i record
the conversations i listen to the
conversations again i
i uh jot down thoroughly jot down all
the mistakes that i make and i try to go
through them and try to improve upon my
um you know upon my
my conversations so that's that's what i
do in a nutshell
and if you have the time and the money
to hire tutors and
it's definitely within your reach a
financial reach possibly
if if if you have a couple of uh euro to
uh you know to spend on that invest on
that because it's really not
that expensive to hire a tutor nowadays
and they're excellent tutors out there
samuel fuentes i think he has a question
in french
do you understand characters like
japanese and chinese characters
and can you motivate me um to learn
languages like you i would say yes i can
understand
characters uh japanese and chinese i'm a
little bit
rusty nowadays because i haven't so much
has touched these two languages in a
long time
uh so but i i can i could and uh i think
it's
would not be very complicated to go back
to them and as for motivating
you have to learn to motivate yourself i
can't motivate you
but maybe you can watch my youtube
videos on and off you know when you get
a little bit demotivated you can turn
off youtube and you can watch
polyglots that motivate you
i remember that there are some polyglots
there are some people on youtube that
really motivate me
and when i feel like i'm a little bit
tired or for whatever reason i don't
want to learn a language which happens
rarely i have to confess then watching
videos by for example steve kaufmann
laoshu 55 000
i remember when i was watching laoshu's
videos
he unfortunately recently passed away
but he
always inspired me because he was going
around in malls talking to people he was
making lists as i did back in the day
when i was like
15 i remember i was making lists of
languages that i wanted to learn and i
tell myself damn you know
so many languages so much passion so
much energy
so much life so much contact with people
so many interactions laughs smiles
that's what makes me tick you know at
the end of the day is communication with
people it's talking to people living
situations
laughing eating uh eating with with with
foreigners
with people citizens of the world so i
think that
a way of you have to find your own way
of motivating yourself but seeing others
using that language or that their
languages
is inspiring but then you know
when you find ways to motivate yourself
then bingo and
you you have to experiment to see what
what really makes you tick what i know
what makes me take you know so
both if when i go on surf the internet
and when i
find the motivation and the energy that
i have in myself
i always tell myself that one language
no matter which language will
bring you closer to uh millions of
human beings you know and even if it's
just thousands they're in the thousands
and not in the millions it's still worth
it
because it can change your life and it's
definitely changed mine
so uh
yes akers says his name is moses brother
yes but laoshu
55 000 is moses moses mccormick
so uh if you haven't if you don't know
who moses is you should definitely check
his uh his youtube channel he's a
fantastic guy
so um let me see how to make learning
fun when you're under time pressure
well it depends you know if you're it
you you have to in that case you have to
find yourself in a situation where you
don't feel pressured for time and i
think you have to create time to do that
um so if you if you find yourself
constantly pressed and stressed when you
have to change your schedule
um i had a couple of students of mine
who have been using my bilingual
translation method and they were telling
me oh my god i have just like 35 minutes
and then my wife is going to call me and
then the kids
and i said well maybe you can find
another time to do that so that you
if you're learning under pressure that's
you know it's it's not good so
you have to find a different time
schedule that suits your needs
nikola which books are you're reading at
the moment
i'm reading contact by carl sagan i
don't know if you ever heard of carl
sagan he's one of my favorite
astronomers astrophysicists
uh then i'm reading why we're here he's
another astrophysicist
and astronomer and then
i'm reading a bunch of other books
actually i'm reading another book by
sergio fernandez i don't know if you
ever heard of sergio fernandez he's an
entrepreneur spanish entrepreneur
and then i'm reading um eating animals
by uh
by foe saffron saffron foe i think
that's his name
and then i'm reading another book i'm
reading i have a bunch of books i don't
have them here they're in the other room
but i'm basically reading three or four
uh oh and another book
by kate brown about chernobyl she wrote
it three
three years ago and the last one is a
book
um about fukushima so i'm reading about
nuclear disasters and physics basically
nowadays so
rhetoric high look i tend to remember
words in some contexts but not
others for example in japanese i don't
know
but later i read and immediately knew
what it meant advice
so
i would say rhetoric um i they're there
i have some notebooks but fundamentally
i what i would advise you to do is to
jot down
um stuff so design
a catch the fish system where you're
just basically
writing not just words but fragments
of conversations you know so just
writing the single words here
that i see is not enough you have to
create a system where you have
multiple access points in your memory so
that you can remember better
if you just write the words these words
simple words that's not going to help
you
so i design a system to catch the fish
system so to speak where
i use notebooks and i jot down not just
single words but entire
fragments of conversations and i also
write where i got them which is really
interesting
interesting i call it the episodic
memory framework so you can write for
example oh i got this from podcast
you write the title of the podcast and
you write when you when you did it
and this allows you to remember things
way better
how you you do things and how you design
the system to review
things is really important and then you
review it review this stuff for a long
period of time
a little bit every day frequency and
long term are keys do not try to cram
words
because your brain will refuse uh new
information if you feed the wrong
the wrong information so
angelique rouge privet luca i've been
learning russian for two months so my
biggest trouble is word order what i'd
recommend
what what did recommend to deal with
this part by the way i have russian
speaking
friends and i try to text her a friend
and try to text her in russian every day
i think that word order in russian is
not a problem
because you can move things the way you
want i think
word order is more of a problem in
languages like japanese that have a
different syntax or korean
but in in russian you can move things
around as you want of course some things
sound a little bit weirder than others
if you move them around but i don't i
don't think that's the problem the
problem is more like cases
to get cases right but i think word
order at least in my
in my book in my case is not a big
problem so you shouldn't worry too much
about that
um so
uh mohammed reading versus listening for
in foreign languages which one is better
i think that we should ban the or and or
questions like is this better than the
other there's no reading
and listening are both very important so
why not
reading and listening so you can read
and listen at the same time
you can just read or you can just end or
you can just listen if you do all three
then bingo and this is what you should
actually should do because every
every action corresponds to a reaction
in your brain so
if you just read you develop a reading
competence if you just listen
you develop you you get you improve your
listening comprehension if you read
and listen at the same time you develop
yet another skill
and i would say why not build all of
them because of
all these of these sub skills create a
compound effect
that is we call for you know
[Music]
speaking a language knowing a language
being able to speak a language whatever
you want to call it
so shang hey luka could you give us some
more pieces of advice for reaching level
c1 in any language i think i
have abundantly spoken about that if you
hear the recording if you listen to this
recording later you will hear
uh you will listen to me speak about
address this uh
multiple times and i also have i remind
you a bunch of videos and
articles um about that
so um luca you make me melt oh
oh thanks how could you i don't know i
don't know what that
stands for but matteo zarantonello hi
look i'm curious to know about dutch are
you able to maintain
maintain it or to speak it with native
speakers dutch people always prefer
speaking english
what do you suggest um so
i'm curious to know about dutch are you
able to maintain it to speak it with
native speakers dutch people always
prefer speaking english what do you
suggest i
i lived with um i lived with a dutch
girl
for um for quite some time for a year i
think and when
she was living here and also had other
dutch people around we used to speak
we used to run together and we were
jutting down uh you know she was
learning a tie and i was learning dutch
i used to speak it quite often
it's a language i think i speak well but
i don't get to speak it very often so
it's it's weird but i speak german so
speaking german helps me
retain in some weird way dutch so i
don't forget
it but i've been speaking a little bit
with edward
uh you know the the student who happens
to be here and
door setter and who happens to have a
youtube channel you should check that
out if you want to learn dutch
and if you speak dutch uh but generally
i don't get to speak it very often
i get to speak and on and off my
cousin's girlfriend is italian dutch
so i speak it on enough but i don't
really uh
i don't really worry about not speaking
it because it comes to me quite
naturally when i speak it and
i get back to it pretty pretty quickly
so
um brian hi luca everyone has different
personalities which means different
stunning habits and techniques your
thoughts
sure i think what that's true i think
there are universal principles when it
comes to learning but i also believe
that you should do what makes you tick
so if i
say hey guys my bi-directional
translation method is fantastic you try
it and it's not your taste
then by all means you should do
something else but i believe that there
are some universal principles like
learning every day learning for a long
period of time
caring more for frequency first than uh
intensity
and then uh getting to use the language
getting
comprehensible comprehensible and
interesting content these are all
universal things
that all good learners um abide by
then the style how long you learn how
you know how you um you know
do the different engage in different
activities that stop to you it depends
on you it depends on
the on the learner that's the reason why
also sometimes
school fails at teaching or training uh
people
because they just create a size one size
fits all
uh method that you know does not adapt
to the single learner
every learner in a class of 20 people 25
every learner is different
if you give them a specific topic and
you tell them hey let's listen to this
article about
astronomy but um you could not care less
about astronomy you're not
going to be willing to learn so i think
that language
learning has to is is a is a personal
path
and everyone is different in this regard
so um
hi luca medium pandereta i think that's
your name any advice of learning polish
from scratch from english
there is no asimo for polish english
speakers that's true
but you have a lot of stuff on the
internet
i think maybe kevin can write it if you
go to our website you can find
a lot of resources for learning polish i
would very
much recommend real polish piotr so he
has a website it is called real polish
you can start from
scratch i used to listen to his podcast
all the time i think he does an amazing
amazing job
and then there's another girl who goes
by the name of paulina lipietz i had an
interview with her recently
also on spreaker i think she does often
these two do a fantastic job
so i so you don't need any asimo uh if
you have paulina lipiats and piotr from
real polish
if you have these two resources and they
have built uh scaffolded and built
an entire infrastructure of you know
you can learn languages you can learn
polish from scratch a1 a2 they have
like conversations it's just amazing
what they have created just wonderful
it's just wonderful people and i'm super
happy that they're around
so um let me see here
polar polar bear interesting name polar
bear hey lucas is it worth to learn a
language if you can't find the
motivation to learn and i'm a beginner
in korean but i can't find a strong
reason to learn it
if you're not motivated enough then
either she should drop it or you should
question your motives
you should ask yourself why am i
learning korean because there's no
worse thing than just starting something
if you're not motivated you know and
i believe that's the reason why when i
learn a language i always make sure that
i'm
i'm motivated that i know exactly what
i'm learning but i've i've
you know i have some um compelling
reasons why i'm doing that i visualize
myself in the future speaking this
language and
normally the dream the language dreams i
have tend to
to you know i tend to fulfill all my
language dreams because
i have a very strong motivation i don't
it didn't happen that i started learning
a language and i was not motivated to
learn that was romanian
and then i told myself never again i
want to learn a language to fluency
sometimes i find it more difficult than
i thought like in the case of japanese
so i um for example i found it very
difficult to learn
but i will go back to it so if you're
not motivated to learn
a korean either you're not motivated
there's no compelling reason or maybe
there is but you still have to
ask yourself the right questions or
maybe you have to connect with a person
who makes you tick or connect with
something related to the culture that
makes you tick otherwise you're not
going to be learning
language learning is a long road you
have to make it happen every day we
still have
i think five minutes so i um i also
promise my team will keep it within the
75
minute mark so let me see if you have
any other
interesting uh resources here
so mattel's diaz which oops i lost your
question mateos i'm sorry
so let me see here nope i
i can't i can't find um i can find your
question anymore for whatever reason
giovanni scalius hi i guess you're
italian hi lukas sorry if you already
answered to
answer this what do you think is the
best way to learn japanese kanji because
i'm trying to immerse but i don't
understand anything of course
the best way to learn kanji is not to
learn kanji from the very beginning i
will focus
more on the language than on the kanji
normally a question that
people ask me how many kanjis do you
know and it's irrelevant when it comes
to speaking language i think you should
focus on the language first and then you
should
if you want you can you can learn the
kanji not the other way around
think about this japanese kids haven't
learned kanji from the very beginning
they've learned
later they've learned to speak first in
within their family then they have
learned kanjis
and so you can learn the translator
through the transliteration
focus on on vocabulary focus on how the
language is spoken
by using language learning material
there's a lot for japanese
then you can focus on kanji there are a
lot of memo techniques luka toma
is uh since you're italian luca thomas
maybe kevin you can write the
the you know his website is a good
friend of mine he's a language coach
fantastic japanese speaker he speaks
like a native basically almost
and he has a lot of stuff about kanji
how to learn kanji
you know memory memory palaces and and
whatnot
so you might want to take a look at that
there's also the
heisig method it's a famous method to
learn kanji
but again you can do this on top of
learning japanese
how the language is spoken and not the
other way around do not spend too much
time learning kanji to the detriment of
actually learning the language
here's my piece of advice uh we have
space for one more question
uh when i whenever i feel demotivated i
go on youtube and watch luca and pero
speak about language and i feel
motivated again
thank you co so um
let me see here look at what language do
you think in so ludos tested venezuela
in
english and in italian and in roman
dialects when i get uh when i get angry
that's that's the language that comes
out
so i think that this is it guys uh
could you tell us about your workouts do
you use an app
um i used to use freelance suggested by
one of my team members
sophia but then now i'm using fitness
blender
i love these guys and i'm about to start
a new workout program
uh this monday fitness blender just type
fitnessblender on youtube and you will
see they have a lot of
cool stuff so guys um
thanks a bunch uh for all the wonderful
questions been a pleasure as i said
we're probably going to do this again at
the end of the month this year this this
time was a little bit different we
didn't do it at the last saturday of the
month but
actually at the beginning but the next
one should be the last
saturday the last saturday of april so
if you have
any questions that i haven't answered
it's just because you know
you're asking a bunch of questions and i
love this uh but
i will do my best to answer uh your
questions uh next
time so thanks again and uh
i wish you a fantastic saturday a
fantastic weekend
uh easter for those who celebrate easter
now i think
or for the uh orthodox it's in may
and uh i'll see you guys on youtube very
soon i'm gonna publish the next short
video on monday
and then possibly within the next two
couple of weeks crossing fingers
i will start publishing again on
thursday so there's more good stuff
coming
uh and one of the things that i would
like to show you is
this live this this bookshelf here with
a lot of books
thank you guys been a pleasure as always
and take
care of yourselves and remember learn
languages because it can change
your life thank you bye